-My next guest is
a talented actress.
And starting tonight you can see
her as Monica Lewinsky
in "Impeachment:
American Crime Story"
every Tuesday
at 10:00 p.m. on FX.
Please welcome Beanie Feldstein!
♪ -It's Beanie Feldstein ♪
♪ As we're about to see ♪
♪♪
♪ Monica Lewinsky ♪
♪ When she ain't working ♪
♪ And she got time to kill ♪
♪♪
-It feel good having a crowd?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow!
-There's nothing like
a live audience.
-This is so crazy.
-Yeah.
It's wild, right?
-Oh, my God. We're back.
-We're back.
I want to talk to you
about so many things.
But first off, I want to
congratulate you.
It just was released that you
are going to be the lead
of "Funny Girl" on Broadway.
[ Cheers and applause ]
And I go, "Yes!"
-Wow!
-That's perfect.
This is the first time
it's been on Broadway
in 50 years or something.
-Since 1964.
-Wow.
-Isn't that insane?
-And, I mean, Barbra Streisand.
I mean, just -- I know.
And I was like they couldn't
think of a better,
more perfect person
than you to cast in it.
I'm so happy it's you.
And then when I said I want to
talk about it on the show,
you sent over a photo of you
as a child.
-Yeah.
-Was it Halloween?
-This was my third
birthday party.
[ Laughter ]
I asked for the theme
to be "Funny Girl,"
as every 2 1/2-year-old does.
Not Elmo.
Not "The Little Mermaid."
Please, "Funny Girl"
to be my theme.
-So this is you as Fanny Brice.
[ Audience aws ]
-Yeah.
-Can you believe that
this is happening?
-No.
-Can you believe life right now?
-I feel like I should teach
a class in manifesting,
but I don't know what I did.
[ Laughter ]
I wouldn't know what to teach.
-Seriously.
I mean, I just think it's
so full circle and so cool.
I saw you in "Hello, Dolly!"
By the way,
you were phenomenal in that,
and I think you're going to
rock this one.
-Thank you.
-Did you always do musicals
as a kid?
-I always did musicals as a kid.
I was obsessed.
-What kind of kid were you?
Were you a rule breaker?
Were you a good kid?
-No. I'm a strict rule follower
now.
But when I was a kid, I
don't want to say I was a bully
because that sounds
really horrific,
and that's the last thing
I would want to be.
But I'm the third kid,
and I was, let's say,
like, over, the young kids.
Right? I was like, "Come on.
I want to be with the adults.
I want to be with
the teenagers."
I didn't -- I couldn't find
my crowd in preschool.
So I used to carpool --
-Preschool.
-I used to carpool with
this girl, Katie,
who is lovely and wonderful.
But when we were kids, she
used to cry every single morning
that her mom would leave.
And I couldn't take it
after a while, Jimmy.
[ Laughter ]
And I went up to her,
and I grabbed her
like where your tie is.
And I pulled her to my face,
and I said,
"Katie, the mommies leave
and the mommies come back.
What part of that
don't you understand?"
[ Laughter ]
And I threw her to the ground.
And the teachers called my mom,
and they were like,
"We shouldn't be laughing,
but it was so funny."
-"Mommies drop you off,
and the mommies pick you up.
Okay? Happens every day."
-"How is it not getting in that
she will come back?
I promise you."
-I love that.
-So I was such a little meanie,
but then I grew into a Beanie,
and it was fine.
It was all good.
-Beanie, I got to talk about you
playing Monica Lewinsky.
"Impeachment:
American Crime Story."
-Yes.
-Everyone is talking about it.
I don't know if you've --
You're on every commercial,
on every channel.
And it's amazing.
I've only seen
the first episode, but, man.
You got me
right off the beginning.
I go -- I just feel for you
and I go,
"I lived through that at the
time not having these emotions."
And I'm watching this girl just
kind of scared and in trouble
and like, "What's going on?"
And, now, Monica Lewinsky
is actually
producing the show as well.
-Yeah.
-So you got to meet her
and talk to her?
-I did.
It's been an incredibly
moving experience, Jimmy.
I mean, I was in London
when Ryan Murphy called me.
And he -- I answered this
American number I don't know.
And I'm like, "Hello?"
and he's like,
"Beanie, it's Ryan Murphy."
And I was like --
My butt fell off, okay?
[ Laughter ]
And he was like, "Do you want to
play Monica Lewinsky
in the third installment of
'American Crime Story,'
and do you want to be
a producer?"
And it was the most
empowering moment.
It was such a massive deal.
And it's her real life.
And so we felt that she should
be a part of telling her story
because in the '90s,
she was actively silenced by
the Office of
Independent Counsel
because of her immunity deal.
She was not permitted to speak
for herself,
and she was literally silenced.
So people think they understand
her story
and the stories of Paula Jones
and Linda Tripp, but they don't.
And we're hoping to really peel
back the curtain and show you
what was really happening
at that time.
-Well, you knocked it
out of the park.
I want to show everyone a clip.
Here's Beanie Feldstein
as Monica Lewinsky
in "Impeachment:
American Crime Story."
Take a look at this.
-I have to say,
you're such a knockout.
I just assumed you'd be dating
some big D.C. player.
-[ Sighs ]
-What?
-I'm not dating.
-Why not?
-I'm kind of in something.
-And yet you feel lonely?
-Yes, affirmative.
-Well, that's no good.
Tell me about him.
-It's, uh...
It's just he's, um, unavailable.
-Someone long distance?
Someone from work?
Someone important?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Beanie Feldstein!
"Impeachment:
American Crime Story"
airs Tuesdays at 10:00 p.m.
on FX.